[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous avez vous déjà essayé de
manger avec les coudes
c'est vrai c'est une question un peu
bizarre pourtant on va faire l'exercice
là maintenant imaginez vous avec votre
famille avec vos potes dans un repas
fermez les yeux et essayer de manger
avec vos coudes on est d'accord c'est un
peu compliqué pourtant j'ai dû
m'habituer
et c'est devenu normal pour moi et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi il est 7
heures du matin le 18 mai 2006 et comme
chaque jour maman viens me réveiller
pour aller à l'école mais ce matin là
c'est c'est bizarre il ya un truc de pas
normal
j'ai mal à la tête j'ai mal à la nuque
geda température et mon état va
s'aggraver au fil de la journée
parce que pendant l'après midi je vais
monter jusqu'à 40 de fièvre et alors que
je suis dans mon salon avec mon papa je
suis allongé sur sur le canapé lui
travaille juste à côté en télétravail et
sans aucune raison
je me suis mis à compulser les secours
arrivent on ne transporte jusqu'aux
urgences de lunéville et là je suis pris
en charge par la personne qui m'a
réellement sauver la vie cette personne
c'est la pédiatre urgentiste faut
s'imaginer aux urgences dans une chambre
challenge et sur lit d'hôpital
complètement dans les vapes avec la
morphine et parents à côté du lit et la
pédiatre qui va les voir et qui leur
annonce que leur fils est atteint d'une
méningite bactérienne avec un purpura
fulminans et à ce moment là on est loin
d'imaginer tout ce que ça va engendrer
provoqué cinq mois de spitz alisation
cinq mois d'hospitalisation commence à
partir de là on va tester tous les
traitements possibles et imaginables
mais rien n'arrête cette foutue bactérie
qui se baladent dans mon corps et qui
brûlent petit à petit mais vaisseaux
sanguins et qui finit par nécrosés mes
pieds et mes mains
alors les médecins font des recherches
il teste des choses mais en plus de ça
je vais faire des complications
je vais faire un début de septicémie un
staphylocoque doré en gros j'ai pris le
all inclusive de la maladie je me suis
dit allez je prends la totale c'est
parti quoi non sérieusement il a fallu
beaucoup de temps et au moment où je
fais face à ces complications
les médecins décident de man et
d'une première journée
malheureusement ça suffit pas alors on
ampute d'une autre jambe en suite d'un
bras et ensuite de l'autre bras il aura
fallu cinq mois d'hospitalisation et
l'amputation de mes quatre membres pour
arrêter totalement la maladie alors là
vous êtes en train de vous dire oh la la
c'est horrible ce qu'il a vécu ça devait
être tellement dur etc
mais en fait pas du tout déjà j'ai pas
de souvenir et en plus de ça pour moi
l'hospitalisation sap a été le plus
compliqué le plus compliqué ça a était
là prêt quand le sort de l'hôpital parce
que tout était beaucoup plus complexe
même les choses les plus simples en fait
faire une tâche du quotidien pour moi à
l'époque c'était comme gravir l'everest
six fois de suite avec un sac à dos de
300 kilos sur le dos quoi mais pour ça
il y avait une solution
cette solution s'appelle la rééducation
pour moi la rééducation c'est apprendre
à vivre quoi on réapprend tout depuis le
début
et quand je commence la rééducation j'ai
un seul objectif un seul j à mes parents
à ma famille à mes potes je vais
remarcher et ça je le faire très
rapidement alors avec mon prothésiste on
travaille comme des fous pour trouver la
prothèse d'idéal je m'entraîne entre des
barres parallèles et un jour je fais mes
premiers pas et là c'est ma première
vraie victoire je vois le sourire sur
les lèvres de mes parents je vois le
sourire partout dans la salle il ya tout
un tas de personnes c'est juste
incroyable et je suis père soulagé parce
que je relève enfin mes fesses de ce
fauteuil qui était beaucoup trop
encombrant pour moi qui m'ont empêché de
d'aller dans certains endroits et faire
certaines bêtises avec mes potes quoi
et je suis soulagé je suis content je
suis émerveillé et dans ma tête je me
dis c'est le premier combat mais ils
vont en avoir plein d'autres aisée sur
marché avant de savoir écrire avec mes
deux bras ou manger avec mes deux coups
de justement je fais énormément de
progrès je suis de plus en plus autonome
mais une chose reste encore très très
très difficile pour moi cette chose
c'est le regard des autres c'est vrai je
comprends pas pourquoi quand je retourne
dans des endroits auxquels j'étais déjà
allé avant de tomber malade
tout était différent pourquoi les gens
me regardaient comme si j'étais un
zombie mois pour moi je n'avais pas
changé je restais théo pourtant tout
était différent et ça me faisait mal
j'essayais de me cacher j'ai essayé de
dissimuler au maximum mon handicap
pourtant il est quand même assez visible
quoi donc c'était difficile et je
souffrais énormément au point de même
plus vouloir sortir de chez moi
mais un jour je vais faire une rencontre
qui a changé ma vie
cette rencontre c'est avec philippe
croizon
c'est le mec qui a traversé la manche à
la nage on est amputé des quatre membres
comme moi on a échangé longtemps au
téléphone et un jour il a fait la
surprise de venir me voir un week-end en
lorraine et là c'est encore une fois un
soulagement parce que je le vois arriver
en voiture avec sa femme jeu vidéo à
super g pouvoir conduire le même pouvoir
avoir une amoureuse extraordinaire quoi
donc on échange
il me donne des conseils je donne les
miens et quand je suis un peu plus à
l'aise je lui ai fait part de ses doutes
et de de ce petit complexe que j'ai en
fait en sortant dans la rue quand les
gens me regardent et m'a dit une simple
phrase une phrase qui a totalement
changé ma vie à tout jamais il m'a dit
t'es ok ce que tu fais toi avant quand
tu vois une personne différente dans la
rue voilà je me suis à temps mais il a
raison et il a raison aussi je faisais
ça quand je vois une personne à qui
manquait une jambe
une personne qui marchait avec une canne
blanche je me souviens qu avant de
tomber malade
mes yeux étaient rivés sur ces gens là
quand je me promenais dans la rue et à
partir de là
j'ai réussi à faire totalement
abstraction du regard des autres
aujourd'hui je suis même heureux quand
les gens viennent me voir dans la rue et
me demande ce qui m'est arrivé
ou encore pour aller plus loin je suis
même content quand les gens osent faire
des vannes sur mon handicap et je suis
même le premier à en rire
d'ailleurs regardez ce soir on est réuni
pour un talkie s'appelle faire un monde
à portée de main c'est peut-être captivé
salle kandahar
mais cette rencontre avec philippe elle
va aller encore plus loin
un jour il me demande de venir le voir
en train de s'entraîner pour traverser
la manche et à la fin de son
entraînement il me demande de le
rejoindre dans l'eau ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quelle époque
ma plus grande phobie c'était l'eau ça
peut paraître complètement fou quand je
vous dis ça l'a tout de suite mais je
peux vous assurer que l'homme faisait
peur que ce soit la piscine l'océan bref
dès qu'il y avait de l'eau ça me faisait
peur pour vous donner un exemple quand
il s'agissait d'aller à la piscine avec
l'école j'étais souvent malade j'essaie
de trouver des excuses pour ne pas y
aller mais là par fierté je prends mon
courage entre voilà autre demain si je
peux me permettre
et je mets dans le vestiaire avec ma
maman que je me souviens très bien
elle m'aide à mettre mon maillot de bain
mon bonnet mes lunettes est sur le
chemin du retour
j'attrape tout ce que je peux une free
des brassards une bouée une ceinture
bref j'en ai partout autour de moi je
suis ridicule mais je suis quand même un
peu courageux parce que j'y vais je me
retrouve au bord de l'eau je saute
évidemment je fais un plat et là je suis
pris de panique
j'suis pas bien franchement je suis pas
bien je stresse alors je ressors
immédiatement mais à ce moment là je
suis énervé déçu ne pas avoir pu montrer
à mes parents et à philippe que j'étais
capable de faire comme lui alors en
rentrant chez moi je cogite je cogite
mais j'arrive pas oublié ce
ce moment là tu énerver encore et je
vais demander à mon père de m'inscrire
dans un club de natation
alors c'est assez drôle parce que la
première fois quand je vais à
l'entraînement je vais même pas dans
l'eau je reste une heure assis sur mon
fauteuil au bord de la piscine mais je
me familiarise un peu avec le contexte
la semaine d'après je retourne à
l'entraînement je fais un effort que je
descende mon fauteuil
mais vous savez dans les piscines
municipales il ya toujours des escaliers
alors je reste assis sur les escaliers
jaune type b et je ressors la semaine
d'après je retourne à la piscine avec
mon papa
ces cartes un petit peu des escaliers et
la jeune âge jusqu'à ses bras la semaine
d'après je fais mon premier aller-retour
la semaine d'après je fais mon premier
100 m ai je fait énormément de progrès
comme ça au fur et à mesure jusqu'au
jour où en nageant
je réfléchis et je me dis attentes et
aux mets l'eau la natation c'est le seul
élément qui va te permettre de faire
comme tout le monde c'est vrai quand
j'arrive à la piscine j'enlève mes
prothèses je descends mon fauteuil et
jeune âge comme tous les autres valides
qui nage dans les lignes d'eau à côté
parce que si demain je veux faire du
basket n'y a pas de souci le pouvoir
faire du basket mais je vais il va
falloir que je le fasse en fauteuil si
demain j'ai envie de faire du tir à
l'arc
je veux faire du tir à l'arc il va
falloir adapter un arc avec une prothèse
tout est possible assure par contre moi
j'ai pas envie de ça j'ai envie de faire
comme tout le monde et en plus la
sensation que j'ai dans l'eau c'est une
sensation de liberté et de légèreté que
j'ai pas dans au quotidien c'est vrai
avoir des prothèses sous 40° en pleine
canicule à paris ça jamais été très
agréable alors que d'en loger plus tout
ça et c'est un kiff incroyable c'est
tellement actif que je vais me mettre à
la compétition en 2012
j'ai 12 ans je pars au championnat de
france et je fais une médaille d'or sur
50 m dos je me dis qu'il ya peut-être
quelque chose à faire quand même
l'année d'après je pars en 2013 de chez
mes parents pour aller déménagé à 500
kilomètres du petit cocon familial pour
pouvoir nager deux fois par jour au
creps de vie le sport études et le sport
de haut niveau quoi forcément fait
progresser
en 2015 je pars aux championnats du
monde de glasgow en 2016
je suis le plus jeune nageur même
athlète de la délégation française à
partir aux jeux paralympiques de rio et
ensuite je suis deux fois vice-champion
du monde sur 200 m et 100 m nage libre
aux championnats du monde de mexico
aujourd'hui j'ai encore plein de défis
en tête plein d'exploit j'ai plein de
rêves d'ailleurs le prochain c'est celui
de de partir en novembre avec deux
autres personnes malia metella et
mathieu vie de voûte en totale autonomie
et traverser le lac navigable plus haut
du monde le lac titicaca au pérou
aujourd'hui je fais pas que nager j'ai
aussi d'autres objectifs comme celui de
changer le regard sur le handicap et
même si on veut aller encore plus loin
changer le regard sur la différence au
sens large
pour ça j'ai la chance de jouer chaque
année dans la série vestiaires sur
france télévisions je suis devenu
chroniqueur pour le magazine de la santé
et je suis même devenu mannequin pour la
plus grande marque de cosmétiques pour
hommes au monde
ouais ça a de la gueule alors pas se le
cacher vous inquiétez pas je peux plus
avoir les chevilles clients de toute
façon donc ya pas de problème non là
dessus vous inquiétez pas je suis hyper
bien accompagné je pourrai jamais avoir
la grosse tête
et si aujourd'hui je décide de faire
toutes ces activités c'est pour vous
prouver qui peut nous arriver n'importe
quoi à n'importe qui à n'importe quel
moment mais qu'à chaque fois on peut
rebondir et s'en sortir c'est aussi pour
dire à toutes les personnes qui n'ont
plus confiance en elle parce qu'elles se
trouvent trop grande trop petit trop
grosse trop mec trop noir trop blanche
une seule phrase fait
de votre différence une force merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]